most accurate forecast on 8 news now I
would have split the gas with you okay
it would be worth the drive it sure
would look beautiful there hey it's
beautiful here at home too dry air now
we've got the sunshine back those high
clouds have moved on have as little as
15 humidity is a good average for most
neighborhoods dew points are down around
10. that just means there's not much
moisture out there temperatures are
warming up from those 30s and low 40s
this morning back into the 50s and some
60s now 57 out at Red Rock we still have
light wind light wind and dry air you
can see just a little bit of that haze
around the valley but it's still a
beautiful Tuesday we really don't have
many complaints weather-wise for our
Thanksgiving week upper 50's for
Mesquite and Boulder City mid 50s for
Indian Springs 57 in Pahrump only 62 for
Death Valley 66 for Laughlin and ely's
up to 48 started out in the teens this
morning Caliente started in the 20s now
at 48 mid 40s for tonopod almost there
for Reno so there are a lot of cold
places around the country if you're
traveling it has been very chilly across
the country this week 50's now for
Dallas and Oklahoma but it still feels
like the 20s and near freezing in the
Upper Midwest and even still feeling
pretty cool across the Northeast but
that's kind of typical fall and
Thanksgiving weather 70s in Orlando 90
in Miami then now that's bikini
Thanksgiving weather there are the
middle of the country pretty clear and
cool there's another system moving into
the Pacific Northwest and there are
showers stretched out across the Gulf
Coast that could cause some slowdowns
around Houston and areas of Florida
later today into tonight a cold front
we'll pick up some more breezes for us
by tomorrow and now most of the rain and
the snow will affect the Pacific
Northwest these are stagnant air
advisories there hasn't been much wind
up here so the rain the snow and the
breezes are a welcome sight for the
folks in the Northwest as it helps to
clean up the air in that part of the
West for us a nice clear skies I think a
lot of those high clouds that we see up
to the northwest of us now will fall
apart before they get here so we'll
enjoy the sunshine 62 degrees normal
high is 64. so we've got a little
warm-up coming tomorrow before
Thanksgiving and the bus rolls in with
lunch time to temperatures in the low
60s yep there's the eight news now crew
ready for dinner as we always are 59 by
dinner time Tom Turkey is like hey
there's no room on the bus for me well
you know you better get on the bus
because you have to be somewhere by
Thursday mid 60's tomorrow down to low
60s still some Northerly breezes
Thursday but a beautiful holiday weekend
for shopping entertaining family and
friends and then driving them back to
the airport so they can go home John
what